when time travel gets involved there
isn't much that isn't possible and with
so many possibilities on the table it's
easy to choke the air with questions in
the aftermath of Terminator dark fate
this franchise has as many dangling plot
threads as ever sadly we learn early and
Terminator dark fate that John Connor is
no longer in the land of the living even
though the only bad guy Terminator we
meet in Terminator 2 is Robert Patrick's
t1000 in dark fate we learned Skynet
covered all of its angles and sent more
terminators back in time that we didn't
know about after the events of
Terminator 2 one of those terminators
the same model as the classic
Schwarzenegger cyborgs were used to
kills John Connor in front of Sara with
Skynet no longer in existence the
Terminator receives no new orders and
decides to learn to become more human
eventually regretting his actions it
begs the question of why Skynet sends
this older Terminator model as a safety
net when the t1000 version we see in
Terminator 2 is clearly superior and can
take a lot more punishment
the real answer is obvious because
Arnold didn't play the t1000 and the
filmmakers wanted Arnold back but
narrative Lee we don't get any kind of
explanation maybe t 1000s were rare
perhaps one T 1000 per time-travel kill
mission was the limit in Skynet central
we'll probably never know when Sarah
Connor explains that the t1000 wasn't
the only Terminator Skynet set back
during the events of Terminator 2 she
doesn't specify that the one who kills
John is the only other terminator since
Karl is still around in a world without
Skynet it's possible that there are
other Skynet models that were sent back
in time could there be more
Schwarzenegger cyborgs out there growing
old and cabins in the woods and working
modest jobs maybe a terminator who sells
vacuum cleaners or an uber driver
it leaves possibilities for future
terminator installments particularly if
they want to bring Schwarzenegger back
sure his death looks pretty final at the
end of dark fate exactly like it does at
the end of terminator and at the end of
Terminator 2 once grace accepts Sarah
Connor into the fold connor explains
that for years she's been receiving
texts with coordinates from an anonymous
source once she goes to the coordinates
to investigate she finds a terminator
waiting for her we don't know exactly
how many times Sarah's done this though
it seems she's killed at least two or
three terminators off screen the
question is why were those terminators
sent back what were their missions who
set him back those files have been
erased oh that's convenient since Skynet
is gone they must have been Legion
controlled terminators so were they all
supposed to kill Dani before Sarah
killed them if so that would seem
strange we're given the impression Dani
has spent most if not all of her life in
Mexico up to this point meaning any
terminator sent to kill her would show
up there and if all the terminators
Sarah hunted down popped up in Mexico
you'd also think she might wonder why
and maybe investigate exactly who the
cyborgs were looking for since Sarah
doesn't seem to have any idea who Dani
is before she saves her from the Rev
nine terminator it's likely Danny hasn't
been legions only target over the years
[Applause]
let's talk about Carl's family do they
really not know he's a cyborg Karl
explains to Sarah that his relationship
with his wife isn't physical still the
boy he's helped raise since infancy is a
teenager meaning Carl's been with his
wife for over a decade you don't live
with someone for that long and failed to
notice their physical quirks it's not
impossible but it's a tough sell there
are a couple of other things first when
Carl tells his wife and child to leave
home and that he won't be back they
don't make a lot of fuss he would think
a family might have a few discussions
before agreeing to completely split
forever second the family has a dog
anyone who's seen 1984's Terminator
knows that dogs don't like terminators
it's why human communities in the future
keep dogs at their entrances and why at
the end of the film Sarah Connor has a
new dog energy p-- how is this dog
hanging out with Carl without constantly
freaking out at first Sarah Connor
assumes that like in her case in 1984
terminator
Danny's unborn child is the key to
defeating legion once we find out it's
Danny herself that grace is desperate to
protect you might wonder how much of the
Danny of the future has seen the events
of terminator dark fate our grace Sarah
Danny and Carl succeeding and creating a
new future or has the Danny of the
future seen all of it before when we
meet the older more battle-hardened
Danny does she know the young girl she
saves from scavengers is destined to
sacrifice herself for her she seems to
be a little affected by learning Grace's
name so that could be the case but there
are some reasons to believe the heroes
are genuinely changing things the future
Danny tells grace not to tell her
younger self that shall grow to become
humanity's unifying figure yet grace
does reveal it so why would Danny bother
giving her that advice if she already
knows grace is going to ignore it one of
the most inexplicable things that
happens in terminator dark fate is that
the heroes get a very unlikely Ally the
US military deciding they'll need an EMP
weapon to fry the rev 9 Terminator
systems Sara gets in touch with Major
Dean who says he's committing treason by
stealing the item for Sara the Rev nine
attacks during the handoff and the
heroes escape to a nearby military
airfield fall on major Dean's say-so the
heroes meet no military resistance and
are allowed to abruptly commandeer a c5
galaxy transport aircraft and receive a
fighter escort in the air just who is
major Dean that he can get them all of
this from Terminator 2 we know that
off-screen Sara had brief relationships
with lots of military types but the
impression given is that none of them
were high-ranking military officers the
idea that this ragtag crew of cyborgs
and wanted criminals could peacefully
commandeer a military aircraft suggests
one of two things
some lazy storytelling or in the world
of Terminator the US government knows
more about these time-jumping cyborgs
than they're letting on maybe certain
officers like Major Dean are tasked with
giving people like Sarah Connor off the
book support if the opportunity arises
in dark fate we learned that while Sarah
Connor and the other heroes of
Terminator 2 succeeded in ridding the
future of Skynet another artificial
intelligence this time a cyber warfare
AI called Legion is what spells doom for
civilization there is one question left
unanswered though to be fair the same
question is left unanswered in the other
Terminator films specifically why why is
it that as soon as these powerful new
forms of artificial intelligence go
online their first thought is to
eradicate or subjugate humanity do these
a I simply see us as inferior beings who
are wrecking a planet they could be
better caretakers for do they see us as
a threat and figure that killing us all
is the best safeguard any of the answers
could work but we've yet to hear them
all we know is that apparently when
computers become self-aware they
immediately want to kill everybody
maybe it's all the memes we made them
indoor computer load up celery man
please yes
who knows terminator dark fate ends with
three dead cyborgs the Rev 9 the t800
and grace what should not escape the
notice of any Terminator fan is while
the Rev 9 body seems pretty well slagged
graces body and the t800 are more or
less intact and we never get any
indication that the bodies are destroyed
it could be that Sara and Danny
destroyed the corpses off-screen but if
not there's a chance Sara forgot a very
important lesson from the first two
Terminator movies in Terminator 2
Judgment Day we learn it was largely
because of the body of the t800 Sarah
Connor kills in Terminator that Skynet
was being developed at the end of that
film the t800 who protects John Connor
chooses to descend into molten liquid
destroying his body unless there's a
body disposal scene we don't see
Terminator dark fate ends with the
bodies of several cyborgs for someone to
pick apart reverse-engineer and create
Legion or an AI just as bad in fact even
if the bodies were destroyed off screen
there are still the scans of Grace's
body taken while she was in Border
Patrol custody this is a question that
someone should have asked a long time
ago in Terminator the super intelligent
AI Skynet sends a single t800 terminator
back in time to kill the mother of John
Connor
it almost succeeds in Terminator 2
Judgment Day the same AI sends a
new-and-improved
liquid metal cyborg the t1000 back in
time to kill John Connor in spite of a
t800 sent by the humans to protect John
and the fact that Sarah Connor is
trained heavily armed and expecting an
attack from the future the t1000 almost
succeeds and now in Terminator dark fate
the new super intelligent AI Legion
sends a single rev1980 back in time to
kill Danny Ramos danny has back up from
a cybernetically augmented human soldier
another t800 terminator and an even more
heavily armed Sarah Connor and still the
Rev nine almost succeeds do you think
you know
one of those obscenely intelligent AI
world killers might just splurge and
send back maybe to terminators sure we
find out Skynet did just that
but the Terminator Skynet sent back
weren't working together
if one terminator completely on its own
almost does the job why not send back
partners what's the big deal maybe even
a three-fer for make a party of it well
isn't this cute - terminator convention
everything about the journey of karl
feels like the end of arnold
schwarzenegger zin volve Minh twith The
Terminator franchise just as the earlier
model does at the end of Terminator 3
karl sacrifices himself to make sure the
rev nine is down for the count when he
talks about telling his family that he
won't be back it feels like he's telling
us the same thing also Schwarzenegger is
in his 70s and his best killer Android
days are arguably behind him but you
never know
Terminator dark fate leaves the door
open for Schwarzenegger return in dark
fate we learned that during the events
of Terminator 2 Skynet sent at least one
other terminator to 1991
there's no reason it couldn't have sent
others not to mention that from the text
Carl send Sarah over the years to warn
her of Terminator infiltration Legion
was sending more cyborgs to the present
day there's no way to know for sure if
Sarah got them all Schwarzenegger is not
getting any younger but he can probably
keep fighting cyborgs for a couple more
years if he wants dudes still in great
shape come with me if you won't deliver
there's probably a good chance that this
really is the end for Linda Hamilton's
involvement in the Terminator franchise
Hamilton apparently didn't even
initially want to come back for
terminator dark fate in an interview
about the movie
Hamilton seemed less than eager to
return to the franchise quipping I've
been threatening to fake my own death so
I wouldn't have to do the next one
if there is one ironically while it does
seem more likely we'll see
Schwarzenegger than it does we'll see
Hamilton it's Sarah Connors story that's
left with more potential by the end of
dar
fate Connor seems to have found whatever
piece she's likely to find over the
death of her son so in that sense you
could argue her story is over but Danny
Ramos still has a big fight to prepare
for Sarah Connor is our only surviving
Ally as a bona fide badass Terminator
hunter who's been killing time hopping
cyborgs for decades Sarah Connor is the
best mentor the future savior of
humanity could ask for check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]